- (la foule): Éric! Éric! Éric!
Éric! Éric! Éric!oioioioioioioia
des gens qui pensaient qu'ils
allantnt voir un gars brailler,
mais il y a un gars qui sourit.
- Un chef blessé,
Un parti autrefois marginal
maintenant à la croisée
des chemins.
- Bonjour, je voulais savoir
si vous étes déjà passé voter
ou si vous aviez l'i
- le Parti conservateur
du Québec est né en 2009,
dans la plus grande discrétion.
Il n'a re due due due due due de
de vote populaire que 9 ans plus
tard, aux élections de 2018.
- Il est beaucoup meilleur
que moi!
- Ah, bonjour!
- Le chef de'é'époque avait
obtenu près de 9 % des voies.
ADRIEN POULIOT, ancien chef,
Parti conserv. du Qc (2013-2021)
- Quand Éric a pris le parti,
financière était très saine,
on avait 500 000 dollars
en banque, pas de dette.
- E
- Éric est bon.
- Adrien Pouliot ava b brigué
les suffrages dans la
circonscription de Chauveau,c,ce
où s'est présentée cette fois
son successeur, Éric Duhaime.
- La combinaison de sa
la question de la pandémie
qui était fffficile pour bien
des gens, je pense que c'était
la bonne personne au bon mx x xe
la voix de toutes celles et
de tous ceux qui souffrent
énormément présentement,
de François Legault
et de l'incompétence
de son gouvernement.
- Bonjour, ç
- Oui.
ÉRIC DUHAIME, chef,
Parti conservateur du Québec
- Écoutez, j'ai toujours
Vous rappelez-vous qu'au début,
on nous disait que ça lèverait
pas, on disait qu'on allait
ça 10 %. Aujourd'hui, on est
rendu à entre 1etet 20,
on a pas mal monté d'échelle
depuis ce temps-là.eseseseseses.
- Quand il parle juste de
décentraliser ou juste tout ce
qu'il propose, je trouve que ça
Je trouve que ses valeurs et
m manière d'être me rejoignent
plus.
- Bonne journé
- L'ancien animateur de radio,
provocateur et controversé,
affirme avoir réussi
son premier pari : obtenireeeeee
et un système de succès d'estime
populaire.
- Je suis un peu stressé.
fait campagne, mais là, quand on
est à 22 minutes èès exactement
du dévoilement des résultats,
on ne peut plus rien faire. a ae
tunnel entre Lévis et Québec
semble avoir fait mouche.
Sa philosophie libertarienne
des taxes également.
- On é été le parti qui,
depuis deux ans et demi,
a défendu les libertésdididididu
les droits civiques, a défendu
la démocratie et a dénoncé
les mesures sanitaires abusives.
du paysage, on peut pas le nier.
- C'est une game à long terme,
c'est un combat d'idées, hein.
Puis,
faire tourner le Québec vers
la droite, c'est une gsssse
affaire.
- Mais l'incapacité du parti àué
les 600 000 voies obtenues
est difficile à avaler.
- Ça a aucun sens.
les lois électorales.
- On vislele long terme, on est
là pour un projet de société.
- Si on en convainc un autre
600 000 la prochaine fois, bien,
on va être dans l'opposition.
- Dema
journée à décortiquer tout ça.
- Ah, oui, oui!
JOSÉE VERNER, sénatrice, prés.
de la campagne d'Éric Duhaimenes
vont lui permettre d'exposer
les idées du parti, et puis les
Québécois seront en mesure de
beaucoup d'espoir pour 2026.
- Merci becocoup, les gens
d'ici, ça me fait plaisir!
Bonne fin de soirée!i i i i i Ée
son parti sera d'abord d'essayer
de se faire une place dans
les débats politiques,
l'Assemblée national